yo crecí en uruguay un pequeño país
entre brasil y argentina con una
población aproximada de 3 millones de
personas
yo no tenía experiencia
viene directo de la escuela yo tengo una
doble carrera en ingeniería eléctrica y
bellas artes
soy una persona de ambos lados del
cerebro me gustan las artes y me gusta
mucho la ingeniería y me di cuenta que
había una carrera en la que podía
combinar ambas creí que eso era genial
entonces tuve una entrevista con ed
catmull que era el presidente en ese
tiempo pensé que sería grandioso conocer
a una de las personas que había escrito
algunas de las cosas en mis libros así
que fui a la entrevista y obtuve el
empleo en la universidad estaba muy
interesada en esculpir ese era mi camino
principales trabajé mucho con arcilla
con papel con cable y al final de mi
carrera empecé a realizar un poco de
computación gráfica aunque no mucho
entonces cuando llegué a pixar quería
ser una animadora pero las personas más
conocedoras
decidieron que probablemente una carrera
de director técnico sería mejor para mí
dado que tenía la orientación técnica
así como el arte mi primer trabajo fue
de director técnico en iluminación
el director técnico de iluminación si
puedes imaginar un teatro y colocar las
luces donde quieras para que el
personaje se vea bien frente a la cámara
eso es lo que hacen los directores
técnicos de iluminación se trata de
enfatizar la historia y lo que queremos
conseguir hacer que se vea bonito o
aterrador o como tenga que ser de
acuerdo a la historia
después empecé a trabajar en acabados y
trabajé mucho con utilería acabados de
escenario y recientemente estaba
haciendo muchos hating en personajes y
también trabajé como un artista líder
para el viaje de arlo
'rating' es básicamente crear la calidad
del material que ves en los objetos
cuando tenemos los modelos son como
plástico en blanco y nosotros hacemos
que se vean de la manera adecuada si
tienes un pedazo de madera querrás a
averiguar qué tipo de patrón quieres en
la madera o cómo interactúa la luz con
el material si hay irregularidades en
ella si refleja
si se siente suave o si la luz se entra
un poco en la madera rebota en el
interior y después sale hay muchas
matemáticas involucradas al querer
entender un sistema así y como la
iluminación interactúa con el material y
cómo lo percibes y muchas veces es muy
gracioso porque la idea que tienes en la
mente de cómo tendría que verse el
objeto es muy diferente a lo que quieres
plasmar en la pantalla a veces voy
manejando veo una nube en el cielo y
pienso que sí sí era esa nube en la
computadora se vería completamente mal y
las personas no creerían que es una nube
pero está allá arriba está en el cielo
ves muchas veces tienes que pensar en
cuál es nuestra idea de una nube versus
lo que en realidad es la nube
para mí cocinar es casi como una
experiencia de viaje es una aventura me
gusta intentar platillos raros que no
estamos acostumbrados a degustar me
encanta usar ingredientes nuevos y cosas
que no puedo ni pronunciar simplemente
lo hago
no tengas miedo de decir que no sabes
algo porque esa es la única manera en
que puedes aprender no tengas miedo de
equivocarte porque esa es la única
manera en que aprendemos simplemente
sigue apuntando hacia lo que quieres ser
lo que te apasiona eso es lo realmente
importante porque eso es lo que te hará
feliz en el futuro simplemente trabajar
por tu pasión